السياره الحلم بددت اماني الطواقين
لشرائها لانها باختصار باتت مركبات لا
تؤتمن او ربما خارقه ليس لمواصفاتها فائقه
الجوده فحسب وانما لتسللها الى البيانات
بما فيها الشخصيه
اهمال واحتيال وانتهاك للخصوصيه هذا اقل
ما تواجهه الشركه الامريكيه بعد تقرير
لموظفين سابقين في تسلا يقولون ان عدساتها
انتهكت خصوصيه سائقيها فمثلا اضوائها
الاماميه المحشوه بكاميرا مخفيه لا ترصد
الطرقه وحدها وانما كل التحركات حولها اذا
تواجه تسلا دعوى قضائيه رفعها مجموعه
اشخاص بعد تسريب بعض المقاطع التي احتفظت
بها في قواعدها بعضها لمشاهد حساسه ومحرجه
واوردت الدعوه ان التسجيلات المتداوله
كانت شديده الخصوصيه اظهرت عملاء تسلا في
مواقف قد لا يرغبون في نشرها دون موافقتهم
كل لحظه الحميميه او حتى لحوادث اصطدام
جعلت طفلا يطير وليس انتهاء بتحويل صور
كلابهم الى تعليقات ساخره
ويعود تاريخ هذه التصرفات الى عام 2019
بحسب الدعوه التي نادت بوقف هذا السلوك
الجائر ودفع تعويضات لم تحدد بعد تصرفات
وضعت تسلا في مرمى النيران والمحاكم خاصه
وانها اكدت للملايين من مالكي سياراتها ان
خصوصيتهم كانت وستظل دائما مهمه للغايه
والكاميرات مصممه من الالف الى الياء
لحمايتهم
لا نثق بها ولا نستخدمها بتلك الكلمات عبر
المستاون من تسلا رفاهيه وصفت بالمبتذله
رغم كل ميزاتها التكنولوجيه وحتى صديقتي
للبيئه فهي على حد وصف الواقعين بين فكي
عدساتها الفارهه الجاسوسه وقبل ايام خفضت
للمره الثالثه سعرها ووسعت مصانعها في
شنغهاي لكنها قد لا تستفيد شيئا اذا لم
تداري فضيحه المقاطع المخ جله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات